rebel wilson is going all out
late 90s britney spears thank you so
much sweetie
the pitch perfect star took to instagram
on sunday
sharing this snap looking just like
britney spears in the 1999 music video
for her hit single you drive me crazy
[Music]
stop seriously rebels ensemble
looks exactly like the pop stars smash
that
the pick is from the set of the 41 year
old actress's upcoming
netflix movie senior year where rebel
plays a cheerleader who
attempts to reclaim her high school life
and prom crown
after being in a coma for 20 years the
movie is set for a 2022 release date
rebel previously shared this
behind-the-scenes video from her last
day on the set
which included a cameo from her co-star
justin hartley
and just knocking off a little thing
with justin what's up y'all
a look inside the trailers and that brit
inspired wardrobe
that outfit of the day why are you so
hot rubble wilson
i just i just am that's why i get paid
the big bugs it's disgusting
and a sneak peek at rebel rehearsing for
that britney inspired number
we're doing it aren't we aj oh but we
are career before here what are we doing
um oh okay you have to wait to see
senior year to see what it up is
that's not a clue you um you might have
worked out what we're doing
yeah is that me up there no
i'm right here okay and now we're just
warming up
it was actually unbelievable yeah and if
all that wasn't enough to give you
major throwback britney nostalgia rebel
posted
this clip to tick tock from the set
rocking that famous pink waitress
uniform and pigtails
writing in the caption quote can you
tell that i'm the biggest britney fan
so in my new movie senior year my
character loves her and we use her as
inspo for our cheer squad
it's cool as for rebel she's looking
and feeling better than ever yeah it's
exciting
last year the 41 year old australian
actress dubbed
2020 the year of health shortly after
she told et
she shed some lbs in a short time while
filming cats
i lost eight pounds shooting my number
in four days
that's yeah there's a lot of physicality
when you see the film
um but also they heated up the set
very hot to almost 100 fahrenheit why
so that we could never cool down rebel
documented her workouts and shared her
progress
with her fans along the way and she's
down a whopping
65 pounds yeah i'm good this year i'm
concentrating on health it's a journey
but no i feel good and last week rebel
opened up during an
insta live about her real motivation to
get healthy when a fan asked why she
decided to lose weight
it first started when i was like going
through
looking into fertility stuff and the
doctor was like well
you have a much better chance if you
were healthier rebel noted that the
doctor's comment
offended her at the time because she
already thought she was pretty healthy
that's kind of what started that if i'd
you know lost some excess weight
that it would give give me a better
chance for freezing eggs and having the
eggs be
a better quality so that's what at first
it wasn't even
really myself it was more thinking of a
future
mini me really back in may rebel got
candid about her
fertility journey sharing on instagram
that she'd had a setback
and while she didn't go into detail she
did go on to share an inspiring message
of hope
to all the women out there struggling
with fertility i feel ya the universe
works in mysterious ways and sometimes
it all doesn't make sense
but i hope there's light about to shine
through all the dark clouds
you